just in time for the holidays the most
recognizable voice in america
is back the halls with bowser
romano sings a romano christmas wish you
a merry christmas
we wish you a merry christmas all your
christmas favorites are here
on two compact discs go
tell it on the mountain yeah
over the hills and everything and the
classics just keep on coming santa baby
coming to my chimney tonight for me
yeah make my wish come true
all i want for christmas silent night
yeah holy night
oh
order now and you get free of charge
romano hanukkah giggles
i made it out of craig trail dreidel
dreidel
hanukkah today romano sings a romano
christmas order now happy holidays